[Music]
good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight there's an awful lot going on
right now the president fired one of his
earlier supporters in Washington former
senator now attorney general now former
attorney general Jeff Sessions will have
details and thoughts on that in just a
minute
but first the big story the smoke is
clearing tonight for the most expensive
midterm elections in American history
the outlines are just becoming visible
the results it turns out are confusing
it wasn't exactly a draw but both sides
can claim victory and of course they are
in the House Republicans did slightly
worse than average in a midterm election
in the Senate they did a little better
some of the races played out as
referendums on the president's first two
years in office other races had nothing
at all to do with Trump in some races
hard-edged ideologues won in others
doughy moderates did it was basically a
patchwork there are no obvious takeaways
from what happened last night
but there are some useful lessons that's
what we'd like to spend some time
talking about tonight what exactly have
we learned from 470 individual
congressional elections some big
governor's races and a full year of
political debate
well the biggest news is that Democrats
just won back the House of
Representatives after eight years they
are thrilled with that obviously and yet
they don't appear to have any idea how
they did it as of tonight there really
is no democratic program or platform or
message there's no democratic plan for
making the economy stronger or the
country safer there's only Donald Trump
whom they despise the entire Democratic
message is Trump the president is often
accused of narcissism making everything
about himself but on that point
Democrats agree with him they think
everything is about Trump to watch this
clip from last night it had just become
clear that Democrats were about to
retake the house it was a big moment was
were the apex of the night and at that
apex a senior Democrat called the set at
MSNBC to announce his party's top
priority now that they have regained
power here it is I've spoken to a senior
Democratic source on the Ways and Means
Committee who says tonight
breaking news they do intend to request
president Trump's tax returns getting
your hands on those Trump tax returns as
everyone knows would be a big deal for
the committee getting Trump's tax
returns that's the priority for
Democrats not infrastructure not wages
not the looming threat of China or drug
Udi's in this country the shrinking
middle class not even health care
Trump's tax returns that's what
Democrats really want ok maybe they'll
get them maybe I'll get those returns
what then what exactly will we learn
from Trump's tax returns that a casino
owner once employed a clever accountant
that he made less than he claimed he did
well anybody be shocked by any of that
will anyone care about any of that
whereas with the stormy Daniels saga
that went on forever will voters find
themselves titillated for a moment and
then lose interest
what are Trump's tax returns have to do
with them anyway their premiums haven't
gone down it's all just noise almost all
of this is just noise and for the rest
of us there's a pretty simple lesson and
you'd think Democrats would have figured
it out but they have not figured it out
congressman Jerry Nadler will likely be
the chairman of the House Judiciary
Committee just today now there was on a
train back to Washington from New York
and he was overheard by somebody laying
out his legislative priorities first on
the list not making this up impeaching
Brett Kavanaugh and removing him from
the Supreme Court apparently that's what
Democrats really believe voters want
more than anything else get that
Cavanaugh guy off the court congressman
Adam Schiff of California meanwhile is
poised to take over the House
Intelligence Committee he's been the
ranking member there for the last couple
of years he says that come January when
he takes over his main priority will be
intensifying the Russia probe because
it's not intense enough or long-standing
enough Schiff apparently thinks that he
can prove that Vladimir Putin somehow
stole the 2016 election with a few dozen
Facebook ads that hardly anybody saw can
shift early prove that who knows
maybe what we can know for certain is
that nobody outside Washington will care
at all if he does prove
the entire Russia conversation is
irrelevant and dumb that has been proven
already it has nothing to do with
anything and everybody knows it
Democrats are the only ones who don't
know it yet as of right now the entire
Democratic platform can be summed up in
one sentence
Donald Trump is a bad person well that's
really plain to run on in the next
presidential election which incidentally
starts today right now good luck with
that it's a virtual guarantee that Trump
will serve a full eight years if you
make it about him and by the way so has
all the race talk that's not helping you
somewhere along the way Democrats became
convinced they could win elections by
denouncing voters as racist the Andrew
Gilliam campaign just tried it in
Florida remember he was asked about the
FBI probe you're a racist for asking
stacey abrams as surrogates tried it
also in georgia did it work no it rarely
works why would it work here's a bit of
hard-earned knowledge for almost 30
years of covering campaigns when you
call voters immoral they don't like it
and yet the left continues to throw out
the racist slur probably because they
enjoy doing it it makes them feel good
about themselves here's ABC's coverage
of the Gilliam race last night watch
this and I think for many progressives
in place like Florida and Georgia
they'll be they'll be incredibly
disappointed and they'll be giving their
white neighbors the hairy eyeball
tomorrow in other words ABC is telling
us Andrew Gilliam lost because of his
skin color and he lost because of the
behavior of people of a certain skin
color maybe she knows that you hear
things like this all the time every day
and yet curiously nobody ever bothers to
prove any of it or even try why because
it's unprovable and that's the appeal
racism is now anything you don't like a
racist is anyone who's in your way
hurling allegations of bigotry are from
the perspective of the left the quickest
way to get what you want that's why they
do it it happened again today on the
campaign trail you called yourself a
nationalist some people saw
as embolden white nationalist now people
are solicited such a racist there's some
people that say that now the Republican
Party is seen as supporting white
nationalist rhetoric what do you make of
that I don't believe I just well I don't
know why do I have my highest phone
numbers ever with African Americans I
love our country I do you call you have
nationalists you have globalists I also
love the world and I don't mind helping
the world but we have to straighten out
our country first now that happened at
the president's briefing so you may not
even have seen it because you're living
a real life and not glued to the
internet but trust me if that had
happened even just a few years ago
it would have been everywhere it would
have been international news an
accredited White House reporter calling
the President of the United States a
white supremacist holy smokes
but now it's just any other day on cable
news nobody really believes that the
reporter means it it's posturing and
therefore it is boring the claim racist
is losing its power from overuse
diminishing returns have been reached if
you've got a problem nationalism it
might be better just to argue against
nationalism that way we might all learn
something in the meantime Republicans
should understand that Democrats call
them bigots not because they believe
they are bigots or even because they
care if they are bigots al Sharpton and
Louis Farrakhan are still allowed in the
Democratic Party after all Democrats
obviously aren't too concerned about
bigotry or they kick those guys out
first step Democrats say it they make
the charge because they hope it will
bring them power and power is what they
want it's all they want Republicans lost
an entire Chamber of Commerce Congress
last night
nobody rioted this morning nobody
blocked intersections or looted liquor
stores you didn't see Republican
consultants on television this morning
questioning the results were attacking
the House of Representatives as
illegitimate as an institution it didn't
occur to Republicans to do that it was
just an election you lose sometimes
that's how Republicans thing that is not
how Democrats think they mean it they
lost a few seats in the Senate last
night already they're denouncing the
Senate itself as
somehow undemocratic the talking points
have gone around they're all reading
them watch Joy Behar today try to read
them ultimately she misread the talking
points but she gave it her best shot in
the view watch this so Democrats won the
popular vote last night by 8 million
votes right they lose in red areas
because I'm not sure that's the
Constitution I mean you can to districts
are gerrymandering but the states are
part of the Constitution
well you can't gerrymander a Senate
election of course because it's
statewide job a hair probably doesn't
know that suppose isn't know really what
the Senate is but she knows power and
like a lot of the Democrats you see on
television she'll will say whatever it
takes to get power Republicans to
understand that but it's not just
Democrats you should have learned
something last night there were major
lessons for Republicans to once they
should pay attention to here's one
voters care about campaign promises if
you don't fulfill your campaign promises
it turns out they notice they remember
and they don't care for it in 2016
Republicans in Congress promised you I
don't know build a wall
get rid of Obamacare defund Planned
Parenthood they got elected on those
promises they didn't do any of them once
they got elected maybe that's one reason
they lost the house last night
here's another lesson immigration
matters not just on the level of
individuals and families and care events
the things that we debate every night
but on the level of entire populations
immigration changes who lives in a
country and who votes ultimately that's
why it matters you never know that from
listening to the coverage of immigration
stories you would think the question of
who comes into your country and under
what circumstances was entirely a moral
issue really a question of personal
decency good people are for open borders
bad people are against them it's always
the message including today as you know
mr. president the caravan was not an
invasion it's a it's a group of migrants
moving up from Central America towards
the border with the US thank you for and
why did you why did you characterize it
as such
as I consider an invasion you and I have
a difference of a button do you think
that you demonized immigrants Nana's
election now to try them I want them to
come into the country but they have to
come in Legally you know they have to
come and jib through a process are you
worried that's enough that's enough
that's enough pardon me ma'am that's
enough this president one of the
universes I may ask on on the Russia
investigation are you concerned that
that you may have not concerned about
anything with you may have an
investigation because it's a hoax are
you that's enough put down the mic mr.
president are you worried about
indictments coming down in this
investigation mr. president I'll tell
you what CNN should be ashamed of itself
having you working for them you are a
rude terrible person you shouldn't be
working for CNN hate to see this become
a news story Acosta is such a buffoon
but he's such a buffoon that the White
House apparently felt that had no choice
but to respond the press secretary
sander Sarah Huckabee Sanders put up
this statement quote president Trump
believes in a free press and expects and
welcomes tough questions of him and his
administration we will however never
tolerate a reporter placing his hands on
a young woman just trying to do her job
as a White House intern as apparently
that woman was this conduct is
absolutely unacceptable it is also
completely disrespectful to the
reporters colleagues not to allow them
an opportunity to ask a question stay
one on to say as a result of what
happened they the White House is
suspending the hard pass of the reporter
involved until further notice so that's
today's Jim Acosta sidebar but whatever
else the exchange you just saw was what
it really was was a diversion from the
political reality of immigration here's
the political reality California was
once a solidly Republican state for
generations it is now among the most
democratic why immigration different
people live there not surprisingly they
vote very differently something very
similar is happening right now in Nevada
Arizona Texas Virginia North Carolina
and many other states and that was
reflected in last night's vote totals
check the numbers
Democrats obviously know this that's why
they oppose borders because it helps
them win elections Republicans by
profound contrast have been very slow to
pick up on this they're very literal
they still think immigration policy is
about virtue Republicans also seem to
think that their economic message is
working they're very proud of the tax
bill they passed in Congress the
Congress that they will control not much
longer Paul Ryan's always talking about
his tax bill and by the way there's
nothing wrong with tax cuts but
Republican strategists seem to forget
that a huge percentage of Americans
don't pay federal taxes by definition
they don't care very much about tax cuts
cuts to taxes they don't pay for them
and for many others the economy is not
measured in stock prices and GDP numbers
their concerns are tangible concerns
what does gas cost can I afford to live
in a safe neighborhood will I go
bankrupt if I get sick these are real
questions for tens of millions of people
the party that effectively addresses
these questions generally wins elections
Republicans for whatever reason tend to
ignore these questions and that's a big
reason they just lost the house but
there's a larger question that we ought
to meditate on the Republican Party is a
conservative party Republicans are
supposed to care about families not just
a little bit but above all and yet
increasingly the American family is
vanishing young people can't afford to
get married or to have children take a
look at the numbers sometime they're
publicly available they are shocking and
they foretell an ominous future for all
of us a country without strong families
is a weak country it is a volatile place
a chaotic place it's a place susceptible
to political demagoguery it's what
America is becoming if you want to stop
that slide support families it's that
simple put another way if you're
supposedly conservative economic program
doesn't make it easier for young people
to get and stay married and have kids
how is it really conservative if couples
are too poor to have children and you're
not helping
why should I as a conservative vote for
you I should not vote for you I
not vote for you I will work against you
that is my pledge supporting marriage
and children is the best maybe the only
way for Republicans or any of us to save
the country
it will also win them elections they
should start right away